Hi, I'm Ian Somerhalder for the Humane Society of the United States.
People love animals.
And it's that shared value that malicious cruelty toward these creatures is just wrong.
However, not too long ago, our laws didn't match our values.
In the 1980s, only four states had felony penalties for animal cruelty.
Only a dozen states had felony dogfighting laws...
...and in some, cockfighting was still legal.
That's why the Humane Society of the United States marched state by state...
...and closed these gaps in the legal framework for animals.
Protecting animals from the worst forms of cruelty is a part of a civil society.
All right!
There you go!
And it's time for every nation in the world to have that.
Help us make a reality.
A humane society starts with you.